I'm okay with like differing opinions a
lot with even the people that I'm with
because it creates like good
conversation and you kind of like learn
a little bit more about yourself when
you do disagree so if I have an echo
chamber I'm not learning anything so
like for example I used to date this
girl who she was so scared of losing me
um so she wanted to be this perfect girl
like this perfect girlfriend even though
I'm in shambles so if I said something
she goes I agree with you if I said
something I got I'm like hold on a
second and I remember I had this
conversation with her and this was one
of the biggest reasons of why I dumped
her was because like I was like you know
we've been together for 10 months now
and I don't know you and she's like why
I was like because everything you say
you agree with she goes I was like and I
genuinely don't think you agree with
this stuff I was like you are so scared
to be yourself because you're afraid
that I'm going to leave you if you and I
butt heads and she goes I just want to
be a good girlfriend I'm like that's not
being a good girlfriend like you are not
I don't own you you are your individual
self in five four three two one hello
everybody uh welcome to another episode
of The Genius brain podcast most likely
it's not Christmas but it will be soon
before your Christmas gift I brought you
Alex Reed
I have been wanting to get you on this
podcast for a long time I just been
super [ __ ] lazy
and when I finally asked you you said
yes so I'm super happy Alex I have a
thousand questions for you so many many
questions because
well for me like I listen to Korean
music a lot since I was a kid you know
contrary to what a lot of people think
on this podcast people think I hate
[ __ ] creative music in general
um not true why would you hate that
well it's just because I don't like a
lot of the music that's out now is that
oh okay like and we you know you know
when I when I was growing up as a kid
like
all that stuff was just you know company
generated pop music you know and it
still is now
um but there was a lot of like artists
that I really really liked right so I
was like a huge fan of all those like
boy groups there was you know h.o.t
xinhua there was
um God headed back oh I'm talking about
way back so when I was a kid I used to
have everybody's posters on my wall I
had the SES posters the Finkle posters
all this stuff so you feel like it was
like more legit like more creatively
sound back then I think back then it was
just they were figuring their stuff out
I mean the music is way better now for
sure especially in terms of like
production and like Korean people kind
of working their own identity yeah so
nowadays like I don't listen to a lot of
it so like for example I so in in Hawaii
there's this uh the store called K-pop
and friends and my my lady is a huge fan
of BTS I don't know any of these
[ __ ] I don't know any of their
[ __ ] names how is that even possible
I don't know [ __ ] about them I don't
know everywhere yeah I know they're
[ __ ] popular but I don't know
anything so in my mind I was so I went
to the store and I go hi I want to get
some BTS stuff and then the person
looked at me like oh you're a fan I was
like no I'm not my lady is so just give
me some BTS stuff she goes well each
member has their own thing and I'm like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
what are you talking about like well
this person teaming and yoongi and see
now I know their names that's good and
timing yoongi and this one has who has a
poop emoji as a [ __ ] character and so
I didn't know that they had their
individual like little characters and
animals and it sounds like hot cake it's
called branding I mean that is branding
too like K-pop that's to me the one of
the hugest differences between Korean
pop and American pop like outside of it
being in different languages is like the
sheer attention to detail and the Really
intricate and careful and thoughtful
branding I think fans like thoughtful
branding you know it's like we
appreciate that you put in time and
we're gonna buy it so they had like
these like it's like cacao friends it's
like one of their things that's the
other guy's name yeah see I know this
[ __ ] and so like I was just gonna pick
random stuff and the person like hold on
you can't just pick random things who is
there who's their favorite members and
I'm like well now I can't [ __ ]
surprise her so I had a [ __ ]
messenger I was like hey who's your
favorite members she goes why what are
you doing is I got her this thing they
had like a memorabilia bag with all
their signatures on it and she was
freaking the [ __ ] out that's amazing you
know when I walk away from a long trip
you don't ever look at me like this so
what the [ __ ] ever but she enjoyed it
though so for people who don't know who
Alex is Alex you who are you
um I'm Alex Reed
um I'm an artist I was a
the first black K-pop Idol you know no
Asian descent and that hadn't been done
before and I was just a really big K-pop
fan and so when I got that opportunity I
headed over there and now you know I
just consider myself just an artist in
general you know an international artist
and I'm a writer and dancer and I'm
creative the thing that I'm curious
about is this right like I've
now I'm a Korean guy but you are oh yes
yes
I'm so curious about number one how did
you even get into the Korean music space
yeah so it was really random like I
actually feel like it's the most fateful
thing like if you don't believe in fate
and then you hear the story you're like
okay
um so my first introduction to like
Korean culture was when my family hosted
a Korean exchange Family
which is funny because people are like
what is a Korean exchange family and I'm
like looking back like yeah that maybe
that is a little weird like why did we
did have a whole family like it wasn't
just the students we had like a mom oh
it was like a mom uh son a daughter and
then even their uncle came at some point
um and so that was like my first
introduction to Korean culture and I
just started getting interested so then
my um you know my my attention was up
when I heard about K-pop
um Ivy was the first artist you remember
yeah so Sonata of Temptation I was like
the first thing I saw and at that point
it was it was old but to me it was like
whoa like this is so fresh and new and
then look at the date and I'm like wait
what has been around
um and I just like went down this K-pop
rabbit hole and I was just obsessed and
like you know at that time K-pop wasn't
like a legit a legitimate genre here it
wasn't like you know you got made fun of
like people were like what like what is
this girl like especially me like of all
people they're like what what is this
you like boys wearing makeup like they
would say all sorts of mean stuff you
know so I just kind of kept it to myself
like I was just like a Down Low little
K-pop fan and um and and then I just I
moved out here and I had signed record
deals I was on Def Jam and Publishing it
with Sony and just like making my own
album and doing my my own thing and then
I ended up in the studio and there was a
writing camp like a song Camp going on
for K-pop and I was like oh how how like
this is random like this is cool
um and I kind of just thought it was my
opportunity to make an impression and
maybe be a go-to songwriter for K-pop
because a lot of the songs are written
in English and then translated into
Korean so as a writer you didn't have to
know Korean or anything like that so I
thought that was my big opportunity and
I was trying to really nail it
um I left a wrap on the bridge because I
thought that would like kind of set it
apart since most writers just leave the
Bridge open
um so I I thought I was setting myself
apart and I was just not in the way I
thought
um the anr was like would you ever
consider joining a K-Pop group
yes so random and at that point we had a
lot of discussion like during the
session and so I thought something had
gotten Lost in Translation I thought he
thought I was maybe part yeah yeah yeah
yeah because I'm like that he like we
were just talking about how
there's you know other parts of Asia
there's Idols from you know different
yeah places Japan and you know but you
know they're not all Korean but they
were all from Asia so
um I was very confused when you asked me
that and my response I was like
I'm not Asian yeah that's literally what
I said and I was like when it came out I
was like oh my God why'd I say those
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but I really
was thinking that he thought you know I
thought it was a horrible
misunderstanding
um and he was like laughing and he's
like yeah yeah I know I know like no
[ __ ] like oh okay yeah
um yeah so yeah I know that
um he said that like his boss had been
wanting to diversify the industry for a
while and they just hadn't found the
right person and um they had like they
had another girl that they were kind of
considering at that time so then I ended
up just auditioning via Skype for the
boss like of course I was like yes like
immediately but at the same time I
didn't want to seem overly eager yeah
yeah we always have to do that right
right I was like yeah I love it and
inside you're just like oh my God
I was just trying to play because I
didn't want them to think I was a fan
girl either and it would just be like
okay well we can't have like just this
like crazy K-pop fan like intruding like
invading this the industry so I just
kind of like played it off like oh yeah
you know like kpop's cool
um yeah like I like I dabble I dabble a
little bit like what we worked on today
was fun yeah
um so I kind of just played it cool and
as soon as I got the go-ahead I was out
there like two weeks later maybe 10 days
I was out there two weeks later and then
I think I debuted 10 days later it was
very [ __ ] fast as [ __ ] yeah it was
actually like looking back it was the
pressure was so intense but you know
when you're like in a high pressure
situation you don't really have a choice
but to just do it you don't really think
about it so at the time I was kind of
just in like autopilot like okay I'm
gonna be debuting my dream is coming
true in 10 days like I gotta do this I
gotta do this so I was writing my parts
for the album I was recording my parts
for the album I was shooting my separate
part for the music video because they
already had the music video for The
Comeback done and so they just inserted
like my part into it it was wild like I
don't know if it was stress or what but
I threw up like during the music video
shoot like I guess I looked a little
funny and the director was like are you
okay and I was like yeah yeah I'm fine
and he goes okay um you know rolling
whatever action as soon as he said
action I just
all over and I just think the stress had
gotten had gotten to me
um that is [ __ ] crazy it was crazy so
like when you're
did you have I mean for a K-pop Star
there's there's so much things that you
have to do right yeah obviously there's
the whole public appearance aspect of it
which you know
in any type of like Asian pop it's a
huge part of it I say it's like [ __ ]
80 of the job yeah like your image who
you are what people perceive you as to
be so for you like did you already have
like a bank background in dancing and
stuff too because you have to do every
[ __ ] thing yeah so that was that was
the plus was that I had already been
like I'm just
I'm really disciplined as it is like
when it comes to my like my craft like
whatever I do I I really go hard so I
even now I dance every single day so at
that time I was dancing six hours a day
anyway
um and so that was one thing that the
head of the company really liked he's
like oh she's already training like she
we don't have to put her through
training because she's already she's
already signed like she you know has
released music has worked with big
artists
um plus I was you know dancing all the
time so he's like oh you know she's good
to go which for me it was like now that
I look back it's like no I was not good
to go like yeah yeah you're not good to
go was the choreo pretty easy to learn
the choreo was fine yeah the choreo was
easy to learn
um but I had drama like I had so much
drama like with the choreographer first
off I had I never talked about this
actually but I had big drama with the
choreographer really yeah like it was
wild and um it was so crazy my books my
I have a book I've been writing a book
and it's gonna be so good when it comes
out it's just it spills all of it but
yeah so I had basically I think the
point of why I should have trained was
because there were the intangibles that
I was missing like maybe singing and
dancing was cool but
I didn't understand like the temperament
that I was supposed to have as an idol
um what do you mean you're supposed to
be more uh like like soft-spoken and
like maybe not voicing your opinions at
all times and maybe not like being so
direct with the boss like I was very I
had a great relationship with the head
of the company like the one who I
auditioned for he was cool like he was
kind of a K-pop Rebel and so we just hit
it off he always wanted to hear my ideas
um but of course I had to rely on
translation to get my ideas to him
because he didn't speak any English I
didn't speak any Korean
um so
it was I mean
it was a mess like it was truly a mess
like to not speak any Korean like so
with the choreographer when you when you
they were just was it a guy or a girl a
girl she just didn't like you yeah she
was crazy just off jump yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] which would she do
what didn't she do no
um let me just say that they're were
surgeries
oh we'll just say that okay yeah yeah
let's just say it was intense and I
wasn't
like I said my temperament wasn't what
it needed to be and I came in like if
something wasn't cool I was coming from
a perspective of
I'm gonna stand up for myself and I'm
gonna stand up for everybody else like
and um slowly I learned that that all
that did was cause more and more
problems like they're not gonna let you
do that like they're not gonna let you
yeah like like Japanese Korean or even
like Taiwanese Chinese like company
culture it's it's very hierarchical so
it's like there's a hierarchy to this
like you don't speak out of turn like
yes like my lady she told me this uh
story where when she worked at a and she
talked about on the podcast too where
she you worked at a Japanese company and
um that was in the States but the
conglomerate is in Japan well those
people came over to the states and she
was working for this food company and
she's basically kind of running like the
American Division for this restaurant
she's the management they're talking and
she's in this meeting as well and then
she's letting these guys know like oh
this is what's happening they look at
her and they go you're a woman you don't
speak
yeah and then she was like what the [ __ ]
is going on yeah and then obviously the
the people who are like the American
Japanese people like took the guys like
you can't speak to people like that here
right yeah but she was like [ __ ] this
company yeah you know what I mean yeah
um
when it comes to like that I'm not sure
how it is now and I'm pretty sure it's
getting better from what I've heard from
like other people but probably the time
which was only like how many years ago
like five six years ago yeah which
wasn't that long ago and it's probably
still like that now but probably a
little bit better but they have a huge
problem with people who they believe are
under them talking back to them yes in
any type of form whether it's
constructive whether it's positive if
it's out of turn they [ __ ] hate it
yes and they will do everything they can
to put you in your place yes and I
didn't know that that's what was
happening that's the crazy part is I'm
like why am I getting punished all the
time why am I getting this weird
treatment and I really didn't understand
that it was like first off they didn't
like that I felt friendly with the boss
like that was already a problem yeah
like why is this girl who just got here
just addressing the boss like she can
talk to him anytime she wants and say
anything she wants to say I didn't know
that was a problem yeah learned that
that was a problem then also I learned
that yeah like if if somebody even older
than you or like higher in the hierarchy
of you know the I titles down here you
know in the company it's like everyone's
above you
um so if something is done to you that
genuinely warrants an apology
you should not be asking for one yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I did not
realize that I'm like why isn't she
apologizing I'm like that was wild yeah
like my clothes came it was crazy like I
didn't have clothes that fit me and I
had a wardrobe malfunction
speaking of wardrobe malfunctions how
are we doing
um
yeah so I'm I'm thinking like why isn't
anybody addressing it or like saying
yeah that wasn't cool like we're sorry
about that and so you know I brought
that up and they're like oh no no no one
is gonna say sorry I was like okay but
like we can acknowledge it that was bad
right so my mom hasn't said sorry to me
ever so really yeah my mom is my mom has
never said the word star she's openly
admitted it she goes like I've never
said sorry in my life she goes I'm not
starting today I'm like Oh okay that's
cool that's so funny I feel like I love
saying sorry like I love like I love
knowing that we cleared it like I love
like if I wronged somebody
once that sorry is said and accepted
like not that I would wrong someone on
purpose but you know if something
happens where it's like yeah I need to
say sorry I love that feeling you say
sorry they accept it well you're the
only woman on earth who's ever said that
again all the comments are coming and I
don't give a [ __ ]
no but
wow all these guys are like who the [ __ ]
is this girl she's saying sorry no but
when um it's I had a conversation with
uh
uh my dad about this and then we were
talking about like how why Korean men of
his generation are the way that they are
right so you know and even then like not
maybe not his generation per se but a
little bit after him too
um and it like he was kind of describing
it as like it's it's like this
generational trauma that's brought down
and how they communicate and tell each
other things right so you know people
also don't realize like in Korea even
like 20 years ago right Korea was
advancing technology technologically but
because of the war which wasn't that
long ago for us for them either like
Korea is one of those countries that had
a really like you know just strap up and
then [ __ ] really progress absolutely
because after they got wrecked yeah they
had they have like this like trauma so
uh the tattooing at the time like the
president was like okay well the most
important thing to us right now is
education that's why you see like in
Korea everything is about education no
matter what the [ __ ] it is like
education is that [ __ ] important
where you come from the level of
Education have is is directly correlated
to how you're treated and how they
believe so it started from that
Reformation yeah and then beyond that
like he was talking about how you know
when I was a kid and like the way your
dad your grandfather used to treat me
and how I use I treated you is also a
reflection of the the hard times that I
grew up in right so yeah there's like a
hardcore military culture so the way
they would teach other people like in
the military or even beyond that was
like literally like treating them like
[ __ ] so if they wanted to get something
out of somebody they would be like
they would have them like just like you
would just be on your feet in your head
with your hands behind your back and you
would you know balance your head and
your feet together as a form of
punishment it's like a sign of respect
and so this is how they would
communicate and it transfers over and
over so yeah that type of stuff is still
within company culture right it's like
and generationally it's just going to
get better and better and better you
know now when you see in Korea like when
I went there what this year in Spring
and I haven't been there since I was 14
and the country is different like I when
if I look at my pictures from where I
like in Sacramento or L.A or whatever 10
years ago from now or 20 years ago it
looks generally the same yeah Korea
looks different it's like somebody took
me into a time capsule like 200 years
into the future wow so it's and it's
weird how now I see individualism in
Korea yeah so 20 years ago I
specifically remember this I I looked
around I told my mother why is everybody
dress the same right why does everybody
look the same the haircut same they
dress the same what the [ __ ] is going on
well now when I went there now whether
it's because of globalization or the
internet these [ __ ] dress
differently like yeah some people are
dressed like right now the hot thing is
just like like [ __ ] like 60s like
grease lightning you know uh John
Travolta type of [ __ ] with a rolled up
T-shirt with the high-waisted [ __ ]
face you're right okay it's like the hot
thing right now I saw all like the young
kids like in hongda wearing that [ __ ]
yeah uh but then you still see some
people a little more conservative some
people wearing like streetwear [ __ ] yeah
but it's all a little different
everybody's wearing different shoes I'm
like what the [ __ ] is going on see when
I was there that was one of the things I
noticed was I was like everyone's
wearing the same shoes the same jacket
actually going at the end of the month
okay and so I'm really excited now that
you're saying this I'm excited to see
even the change from when I was there
until now because I think we'll also
coming from La where everyone is so you
know unique and individual and
um all that going there I just felt this
huge focus on the unit huge focus on the
group and I noticed that just me
dressing differently and being so
different was such a big deal it was so
like what she's so weird like when and
for me I'm like I'm not doing anything
super crazy but I just know that
the focus over there was on the unit and
I think special treatment
no good
um too much individuality too much
speaking your mind was not good and I'm
only speaking within my K-pop you know
company experience so I don't know how
that represents Korea on a whole like if
we're talking about the macro cosm of
the situation but I know that within my
experience within the company it was all
very much like everybody has to fall in
line and be
you know yeah yeah yeah but when I
looked around I'm like everyone has on
the same jacket and the same shoes
that's how it was like legit I'm like
that's not even an exaggeration and the
real thing is and the same haircut too
same [ __ ] haircut same everything
girls were the makeup exactly the same
yeah which you still see that now but
it's not as much as it was before and it
was just very refreshing to see like a
youth kind of
find themselves in a space that's not
like everybody else yeah like they were
expressing themselves like like as
individuals like oh look at this [ __ ]
this is this is kind of [ __ ] nice and
it was a there's a big detraction of
what my vision of what Korea was
obviously when I was younger when I was
14 years old and just to see kind of
like maybe what the internet has done to
them is really great right yes and then
obviously like when you see a lot of
foreigners in in Korea which we we
always had a lot of foreigners in Korea
but now it's like you see them and
they're kind of thriving out there right
so it's a bit different you know what I
mean it's kind of enjoyable probably a
lot different from when you were there
you know I think so because I saw like
well it's also where I was like I always
have to remember that I wasn't living in
Korea for most of the time I was there I
wasn't living you know I was working and
I was in this it's just it was really
crazy I was in a bubble you know it's
really living in a bubble so I have to
take into account that what I
experienced is maybe not representative
of everything else but I did feel at
that time like
extreme like extreme differences in the
way that
um individualism was perceived and in
the way that you know people
um
people looked at you if you were
branching out like I felt eyes you know
I always felt like what are you doing
like get back in place yeah I always
felt that and that's that's actually a
big theme in my book is
um how I saw like kind of my
individuality transfer out to other
members of the group you know and how I
also when I was out of the K-pop realm
like after I quit the group I was still
in Korea for about a month and that's
when I actually got to immerse myself in
Korea and meet other people and do all
that and I actually realized the the
positive side of um of the the focus on
the unit as opposed to the individual
and I understood how um things that I
perceived as like judgment were really
just
um coming from a place of
inquisitiveness yeah yeah yeah you know
or just never seeing it and wondering
what they were seeing but when I was in
the bubble I just felt so judged you
know
um especially like when you're in
countries too where I feel like
sometimes like with Americans when they
go to another country they have like
these perceived their perception of what
that country should be is based on what
their life is in America and that's like
the hard part to explain like I was
watching this video online where it was
they were uh interviewing a bunch of
people who lived in Japan right and
they're all foreigners whether they're
from America whether they're from
Australia or whatever whatnot yeah and a
lot of the stuff that they said and they
weren't being malicious or anything
right but because the question that they
were asking is like what do you hate
about Japan and the stuff that they
don't like about Japan that they wish
they could change it's like you well you
want to change this about Japan because
you're trying to turn Japan into America
right and it's not Australia right and
it's not that yes so what you dislike
about this culture isn't something
that's wrong with the culture is wrong
with your perception about what another
place should be based on what you want
right exactly and so there's no should
it's like yeah based on what's being
should be I always say there's no should
it's not should it's what it is and if
that doesn't work for you then you don't
have to be there but that doesn't mean
that there's a fault in the place for
being what it is yeah and so like for
example we were talking about the idea
of you know being a whole unit right
well
yeah in terms of like your individuality
there's a part where yeah you feel like
you get sucked out but the part of like
where you think of things like
holistically like as a huge group in a
unit you think very altruistically like
you think about your neighbor you think
about how they feel absolutely what
you're doing like that's why you see
places like Korea which is or Japan it's
a lot cleaner than other places yes
because when you throw trashes on your
floor on in that's your country This Is
Your Land This is a representation of
yourself yes and so when I was in Korea
one of the things that I really enjoyed
and I felt this way about a lot of the
places that I was at and I got to ask
questions and I was like oh everybody's
so nice here and they go and four or
five people said this to me they're like
well when foreigners come to Korea you
know us as store owners or shop owners
we want people leaving this place
knowing how great our country is I love
that and so I don't hear that here you
know you know what I'm saying that's
probably not everybody
yeah let's be honest yeah yeah you know
what I mean and that that's like there's
a positive and negative to it right
where sometimes where you have a country
like Korea who is so
you know ethnically or Korean lead like
so Centric that sometimes having an
outsider feels odd to them right it
feels like a piece of them is
disappearing yes you know and I've seen
that a lot where you know a lot of GIS
will marry you know a Korean person and
they find out they're you know they get
a little sad because they didn't marry a
Korean person and then what I started to
understand was that they start to see a
little bit of that country disappear you
know which I I understand to a certain
extent like Korea or any other country
is not like America this is not like a
Melting Pot right and I kind of like
places that aren't so ethically like
um diverse and I know that sounds really
bad is because sometimes I want to go
visit a country where it's just like one
thing one thing and I could go back to
my lovely land right right you know what
I mean and I don't think that's a fault
of their own it's great that they're
being a lot more inclusive or whatever
but sometimes too like
um when I see other like Korean guys and
nor Korean girls and they refuse to like
learn the language or the culture mm-hmm
but at the same time they post like I'm
so proud to be Korean and I'm like
that's great you know nothing about
where you're from it's just lip service
because it's on social media or do you
do you really want to know what it's
like you know to be your Countryman
right and I was born in Korea but I only
came here when I was two so a lot of my
stuff was self-discovery later on as I
got older yeah because I didn't realize
like oh like let's see why this is so
important to my parents right and I'm
like oh like I thoroughly enjoy being
Korean so sometimes when people see
their culture disappear it makes them a
little sad yeah you know yes for sure
and also I mean looking at the history
and taking into account that when you're
oppressed as a people and when you're
held down and you know
all you have is to lift each other up is
each other yeah that's the thing and so
it's like you would be very wary of
others you'd be very wary of others
trying to take down your identity when
that's already been done to you before
yeah you know and trying to like snuff
you out like it would be like that would
go on for generations and that's one of
the things that I realized was when I
say that they're very focused on the
unit and the group as opposed to the
individual I mean it comes from having
to be it comes from like that's they
were you know
being oppressed they were trying to be
like destroyed and snuffed out and all
they had was to focus on okay this is us
and this is how we're going to pull
ourselves out of this not to mention
there were really no like natural
resources you know it was really
literally like we have to work together
bond together and work you know to pull
ourselves up yeah and essentially
recreate yeah and that's the interesting
thing too like the identity our nation
like the Korean experience and the like
the Korean American Experience is so
different you know and I think sometimes
too like there are listeners here who
are like from Korea and they're like
that's not how Korean people are am I
listening here you stupid [ __ ] like I'm
korean-american you know I mean I'm
talking about my korean-american spirits
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you know but that's
their Korean Pride speaking you know
that's not how it is in Korea didn't say
Korea dummy I said here as a Korean
American that grew up in Sacramento
California you [ __ ] Facebook [ __ ]
yourself God bless you you know
is that [ __ ] Korean rage and pride
just shut the [ __ ] up but
yeah like going to Korea was such an
awesome experience like it just feels
weird like I understand like when people
I mean I know this sounds so terrible
but it's like everybody should just go
back to where they came from you know
what is it that's not what he means yeah
that's not what I mean go back to where
you come from you'll understand like
this weird connection yeah you know I
mean like like going to Korea as an
adult and feeling this I was like oh I
could actually [ __ ] live here hell
yeah you know and I love Korea yeah I
could live there I just live there I
know it's pretty cool man like I I mean
for YouTube like did you feel I wonder
like in your case um just because I know
uh like ethnically homogeneous places
are a little it's a little hard on
people who look different and that are
like different ethnicities do you feel
any of that weirdness yeah I felt that
weirdness because first off I like
didn't see any other black people like
yeah because I'm like I said I was
living in seriously a bubble like I was
so busy yeah the idol schedule is insane
I didn't get to see anything I didn't go
get to see sites I didn't get to do
anything until I was like out of that
situation and then I felt like I
actually got to experience Korea and
then yes I did see black people yeah and
I did see foreigners and I went to areas
where you know there was army bases and
then there's all you know everybody
blocking right there like you tell on
like oh [ __ ] look at all these
[ __ ] here they are yeah where
have you been hiding yeah um but yeah
before that it just felt like
um it was just me and
um there were a lot of issues with like
doing my hair doing my makeup and
um things like that
kind of start to make you feel left out
when it's like every single morning
you're going in at 5am and everyone's
getting their hair done and getting
their makeup done and you're just like
sitting there in the lobby like waiting
for them to be like oh oh yeah her oh
put her in that room oh and then I do my
own hair my own makeup so I did like
kind of just feel like there was no um
there's no preparation for me like there
was no like what are we gonna do with
her like how do we you know it's just
kind of like oh she'll do her own okay
great do your own
um and that just kind of made me feel
like an outsider I guess that's where
outside yeah yeah yeah and then um also
like the whole thing when I debuted was
first black
Idol you know there hadn't like there
had been um you know people who were
mixed like with Korean and black or like
you know some kind of Asian and black um
but it wasn't during the idol era so
yeah you know during the idol group era
it was a first and I didn't really know
that it was going to be like I didn't
know there was gonna be so much press on
that actually I had no idea like I
actually just thought I was gonna be
like any other rookie and it would just
be not a big deal when I debuted like I
really didn't think anything of it and
then so I was really like shocked when
it was like every headline was that and
I was like on the news you know and it
was like wait is it this is newsworthy
and then the way that people responded
um to like oh she's ruining like K-pop
like oh yeah like if this is the first
step like she's ruining it you know like
they they thought they I guess it was
threatening the idea of there being I
guess like on one hand I understand
people liked K-pop how how it is and
they're like I don't want change I don't
like change either personally yeah you
know I get I get that to some extent
where they're just like okay we have
enough other music we want this music
but I just think if you're going to
really consider
the fact that K-pop has a lot of outside
influence and specifically from Black
Culture outside influence so then that
just makes me feel like you know you got
to consider that and consider that the
producers and the writers behind the
scenes
you know a lot of them are black
choreographers and then almost all
that's a lot that's a lot yeah so I just
think when you look at that it's not you
then that change looks a lot less like a
change and more like oh just inclusion
and did you feel it kind of like used
you as like their token like it's funny
like my perspective on that changes like
at first it was like no no but then as I
write I'm writing a memoir which is like
pretty much done I just it's kind of
like in editing now and then um a novel
and as I write the novel is more like
kind of an idealized version of the
story like if things had kind of gone a
little more how I wanted them to go
um and also it focuses more on like my
love life and
um it's a fun it's a fun book
um but the more that I write those and
get into those my perspective shifts
where I'm like well if it was so like
just for like the sake of uh the music
and the diversity and he thought I was
just such like a cool composer you know
then like why this and why like it's
like I start piecing things together and
sometimes I do feel a little bit like oh
you know the way that it was rushed the
way that it was like you couldn't even
wait one come back you can let me like
learn a little Korean yeah like show me
around a little bit so ideally how would
you have wanted to go oh ideally yeah
that's the thing is like it really
wasn't built to last like the way that
it was done it wasn't built for like
long-term success it was built for like
a quick hit of press basically is all it
kind of worked for
um and then of course opening the door
for for other
um you know ethnicities to come in so
that was cool and all but um I think the
way that it was rushed it just set it up
to be like an experiment you know like
how's this gonna work how's this gonna
go how are people gonna perceive this
how is she gonna do her hair how you
know it was kind of like The Truman Show
you know it was more experimental and if
I if I had you know
done it the way I would have wanted to
looking back I would have taken at least
a year to train like yeah for sure
minimum minimum and I never had um
anyone teaching me Korean I just taught
myself like so my Korean is like sucky
you know like now I can understand
really well
um but when it comes to speaking like I
know I'm messing up all the stuff
because I know I'm messing everything up
you know um because I just think having
a teacher would have been great so like
if I had a year of really focused Korean
study learning the language and also
learning the ins and outs of the culture
learning what's expected and what's
acceptable and what's not you know I'm
not saying I would always like conform
to what you know the company wanted from
me but at least if I had known what was
expected it would have been way easier
for you to navigate it would have been
easier for me to navigate is that why
you feel like it wasn't made based on
longevity because if they did they would
have taken the time to develop you that
way absolutely yeah like if they thought
it was something that could really work
long term there would it would have been
done differently because they do that
for for idols stars like they literally
have like etiquette classes yeah yeah
how to conduct yourself in front of TV
like what to say how to say it what you
shouldn't say what you should do yeah uh
what you eat right how you bathe how you
wipe your ass right you know but that's
the thing too like I think a lot of fans
don't really
they don't want they no matter how many
times they hear it they don't want to
believe it right they're like what are
you talking about they're all
individuals they do exactly what they
want to do no they don't no they
definitely don't they've invested
millions of dollars into every [ __ ]
one of these kids and they own their
asses oh yeah yeah until their contract
is up and they're free then they can go
ahead and continue with but until that
contract is while that contract is still
there they are the property of that
company absolutely and no matter how
many times these fans they don't want to
hear it they just don't believe it oh
they said that because that's what they
believe in not really you may I mean
maybe but maybe not right exactly you
know yeah so like so when I you know I
had a conversation with a friend who
they were like visibly upset when they
found out all this stuff about uh it was
a group what is this like uh the [ __ ]
uh
um
big bang you know a couple of those
members got some [ __ ] they're like I
can't believe it I thought I knew them
what made you think
you don't know them yeah just like about
our celebrities here in the States you
don't know [ __ ] about these guys some of
these like celebrities that I know they
give a lot of praise to I've met them
personally they're the biggest piece of
[ __ ] I know I know you know and I don't
like that that drives me crazy I'm like
no they're terrible like they're
horrible yeah like these people are
terrible why are we you know looking
that's what I'm saying it's like I
always want people to just separate it's
like you could enjoy them for the
entertainment value but when they do
something [ __ ] up don't be surprised
because yes none of you know who you
don't know them right and that goes like
a lot of ways where it's like people
want to you know insert a lot of
opinions on people who they don't know
or like insert a lot of just like
personal feelings onto a celebrity and
it's like dude you just don't know I
made this like tweet where because I was
I liked um big Bang's uh music so I was
like I just wrote this tweet I was like
big bang over [ __ ] uh BTS where I put
that up
the rage that came out
I just like them more you know what I
mean I didn't think it was a big deal
you weren't trying to like get the Wrath
that was coming your way yeah like if I
said like listen dude [ __ ] scrambled
eggs over [ __ ] over easy eggs we
think people be [ __ ] mad and then
somebody wrote this thing where they
were like this girl wrote this whole
thing she goes you don't know how much
they changed my life blah blah blah blah
blah and I was like I just wrote back
nobody gives a [ __ ] I just said that I
liked scrambled eggs over [ __ ] over
easy eggs and you flipped out who the
[ __ ] cares you know
hey uh and then obviously harsh sensible
people came in and they're like yeah he
could like whoever the [ __ ] he likes I
wasn't [ __ ] on them but even if I
did [ __ ] on them who the [ __ ] can't I
thought you were gonna say that that was
your response I should have known better
but I thought you were gonna say like
the truth of the matter which is like no
I'm really glad that they changed your
life personally that's not my experience
I thought that's what you're about to
say I could give a [ __ ] all right I'm
glad that's what they did for you they
didn't do that for me I don't give a
[ __ ] and I think like just nowadays too
it's just so hard for people like K-pop
Phantom even when I was growing up was
already toxic as [ __ ] yeah it was bad
like it was bad there were like h.o.t
members when they found out that one of
the members actually had a girlfriend
they would send death threats to the
girl saying that they'll finally found
their addresses that they would kill
them they were going to commit suicide
yeah and this is back in the day where
it was a lot harder to reach than they
wrote these letters by hand it was a
tweet these [ __ ] had a quill
and a pen my Candlelight you know and
they wrote that [ __ ] in Korean cursive
so they had the [ __ ] long sleeve in
the [ __ ] brush like this oh a scroll
and then I I'm gonna kill myself like
Jesus Christ like like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] is this I would I remember reading
this stuff and I'm like this is not real
so I when I was in Cape Town too you may
mean it that was there was this group
called dbsk and this is when they split
and one of the the members was there and
he was doing his solo debut in the
states and it was like in this Closet in
K-Town and I saw this girl go up an
escalator looking at him just going
crying her eyes out because she got to
see him and I was like yo what the [ __ ]
is this
this is crazy I mean we had versions of
that too like if you look up like old
clips of people meeting um like Britney
Spears yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] crying yeah you know what I mean
yeah I mean I always think about this
because I feel like I've never been like
that kind of fan of anything like I like
um
Kansas basketball is like the closest
thing like that's what I'm a real fan of
where like I actually my mood is
affected if they win or lose you know
but like as far as like you know
idolizing and worshiping I mean I just
never get to that I'm a big fan of a lot
of people but I never idolize anybody
right I guess it's the Idol because I
can appreciate what like for example
like let's say I met somebody like uh
like Brian McKnight like Brian McKnight
was a huge part of my influence my music
everything else right if I met him I
would be like wow this is amazing I get
to see this guy who I consider one of
the greatest like vocalists like
magicians ever but
it's not going to wreck me you know what
I mean because he's still a human being
and I appreciate the art that he created
I don't know him as an individual
exactly you've got to you know learn how
to separate that stuff yeah K-pop fandom
though it's like no we know everything
I've seen every variety show I know how
they act I know what their favorite food
is it's like you mean that script that
they rehearsed over and over before they
went out and they talked to the company
about it before they went out you mean
that thing right but you know it's just
like I get it but I just want people to
just chill you know but see the thing is
I feel like K-pop fans are the best fans
in the world for that very reason
because I felt like they had my back so
hard before they even knew anything
about me like when the news came out
that I was debuting like a press release
came out and it was like I already had
like unwavering support like they didn't
even know yet if I was talented like
they didn't know if I could sing they
didn't know if I could rap they don't
know if I could dance didn't matter they
were like she
is rapping for us and we're here for it
and I like that because I felt like it
gave me like it took a little bit of the
edge off a little bit of the pressure I
was under so much pressure and it took a
little bit off to be like oh
I have like a built-in like okay these
people are riding for me and it just
like gave me because I'm not one of
those people who like is driven by like
haters I know a lot of people say like I
want to like prove the haters wrong yeah
not me I don't I don't know that doesn't
drive me like it just doesn't so I kind
of like healthy yeah is it healthy
that's healthy because I'm the other way
you're the other way yeah yeah I don't
know for example fake enemies in my head
I'm like yeah who's talking [ __ ] right
now and then nobody is yeah
nobody okay
yeah yeah I just I don't know so I like
having people rooting for me because it
feels really good to be able to like
prove them right you know it feels good
to be like oh they have my back and I'm
doing a good way maybe I'm doing it
wrong yeah maybe maybe try that way I
just feel like I can't focus on like
negativity and hate because then it's
like this dark
like even if I'm proving them wrong it
just feels like now they're in my space
Oh yeah 100 I don't like it I I joke a
lot but yeah I 100 agree because there
was a there was a period where I've
talked about on this podcast where every
bit of my motivation to do something was
hearing something that somebody said
negative towards me and then doing what
they can do and doing it better and
having them come and crawl back to me
you know and it felt really good you
know because that's funny it's an
amazing feeling but after you've
accomplished that you're left with
nothing right like there's there's
nothing left it's like oh you prove them
wrong now what and now you have to look
at them crawling and it's like no that
feels great I don't feel like I feel
great because I feel like man I should
really tell you to like just but I'm not
going to oh no she's not doing it I'm
like oh you're on your knees scrape your
knees until they bleed dry you stupid
idiot but then I'm left with nothing
after because I'm sad so I'm like oh but
I still want them to be on their [ __ ]
knees like I I [ __ ] love it you piece
of [ __ ] you're a piece of [ __ ] and you
deserve to be there right and now I'm
glad that you know that you're a piece
of [ __ ] but they all know well not my
fans my fans are great you guys are
[ __ ] fantastic but he's not talking
to you yeah but like that motivating
factor of like you know trying to prove
the people who you love right it's like
that's way better yeah I 100 agree with
that you know I think that's way more
positive and it's it's a longer goal
that could last for a longer time right
and obviously what I had like it doesn't
it doesn't stay forever you know what I
mean it's brief yeah 100 have you ever
tried like dating in Korea yeah oh did
you what was that like I'm so curious
what the [ __ ] is dating like in Korea
well for me it was like sneaking around
because oh it's in your contract you
know oh yeah because okay so when you're
referencing like like you know the super
fans like going crazy and wanting to
kill people and tell them to die
um so that can really ruin business it's
not good for business so think about
this if I was caught dating
I'm not even gonna say it I was going to
give a horrible example but like that
could render me yeah a Target I'm not
gonna do it but I'm just saying you know
what I'm saying yeah if I was
okay okay now suddenly all of their fans
which are much more than my fans or my
groups fans our fans
all want to hate us because you took
their love because we took their loved
one
away yeah their loved one whatever you
know
um I didn't know that it was in their
contractually it's in there
contractually because that's the point
it's really bad for business that was
explained to me that it's really bad for
business like if if you did get caught
dating a star now all of those Stars
fans hate you and yeah that's bad for
business you could be done like you're
done like especially the girl like I
don't think it's that bad now like I
hear about Idols dating but even at the
time I was there they want the power
couple now yeah yeah they like that now
but no not when I was there it was like
don't do that and so I was sneaking
around because can't hold me down yeah
how is that like is it can could these
do speak English too
um
yes and no the one who I was like most
serious with spoke pretty pretty okay
English Okay
um but it was nice because it was more
like he encouraged me to try to speak
Korean so you could kind of see like if
you for for the fans who really watched
me over time there was like a period
where I started getting a little braver
and Bolder and trying to speak Korean
like even on camera or on a live or
whatever whereas before I was just so
scared like even when I started to know
Korean I was like I'm gonna mess it up
I'm gonna mess it up my accent's gonna
be stupid everyone's gonna be like what
is she saying you know I just would get
in my own head and I would just answer
in English like even if I understood in
Korean so he kind of encouraged me to
feel like
it's okay just try you know just the
same way he said the same way that I
could understand him in English he could
understand me in Korean like maybe the
words aren't perfect maybe I'm leaving
out you know little things here and
there but it was enough where you can
put it together and that made me feel
better so I'm like oh yeah that's true
like if somebody who isn't a native
English speaker speaks English I can get
it like they might not be saying
everything correctly but I can still get
what they're saying you know if they
know enough words yeah so that
encouraged me and so that was good oh
yeah so how long were you dating this
person for
um well
it start okay I have to count so it
started in about
[Music]
it was like about a year a year and a
half oh that's a long ass time but the
thing is we couldn't there was like a
period where like
I wasn't promoting and that's when we
got to really like spend time together
and that was really fun that's when I
was being like real sneaky you know like
leaving practice like oh I'm tired yeah
yeah I'm just gonna go home you know and
then going out and you know doing
whatever and it was great times good
times really fun but then when we were
both promoting and so I couldn't see
each other but we would like see each
other at the networks yeah but we like
he he this is the thing about him
I felt like he he had more to lose than
I did I feel but he was like
he he like I think was amusing for him
like he liked it was fun it was exciting
yeah
so I think like he would he would do
things where I was like
like what what is wrong with you like he
just walked by each other and he would
just grab your ass real quick and then
he would just walk away like what
[ __ ] what are you doing
let's not go that far these are still
yeah these are still Idols but they
don't know who the [ __ ] it is though so
whatever
yeah so I mean it was fun because like
you know we would like kind of find ways
to like see each other like at the
networks and stuff like that how [ __ ]
exciting dude yeah it was fun that's why
I want to try to novel because I'm like
in the Memoir I do go into it you know
when I tell the truth on you know the
situation but it was so much fun to play
with that in like you know a fiction
young adult way because there was so
much to pull from like from like close
calls almost getting caught and like
things like that it just felt like there
was a whole story there that I the
Memoir is more about me and my
relationship to Korea and that was just
like part of it but the novel is like
really love story so you guys were long
distance then because you're going back
and forth yes yes but like when I left
left we like it was done like at when I
left left oh so you guys broke up
because you left yeah
was that hard
um
me and breakups is real interesting
it's not like a sociopath or something
but um for some reason
I
I get over everything in three days
three days three days so you cry it out
yeah if that I mean for me it's more
like
I don't know makes me sound weird but I
feel like I'm very um
I'm very good with like
moving through my life like I feel like
I'm good with like this clothes is
closed yeah yeah I'm pretty good at that
like and I think it's because like for
me like
it was what it was supposed to be you
know what I mean like it wasn't supposed
to be something where we're like forcing
something and we're far away and we're
on different times and he's promoting
like he's a huge star you know I mean
like like it wasn't supposed to be Agony
it wasn't supposed to be like stress it
was supposed to be nice and me having
someone who I could get along with in
Korea when I felt very stressed and
lonely and sad most the time you know
and that's what it was supposed to be so
for me it was like
it was so great and like it was just
great wow that's that's not very Korean
of you though man Korean people they'd
be going through their [ __ ] super loud
they got to make sure everybody have you
ever been to a Korean funeral no dude
that [ __ ] is wild dude there's like this
whole thing where like people will come
see like The Grieving person like if
you've ever had a Korean friend and you
went to like this like traditional
Korean funeral is going to be like the
person who's grieving the person and
they'll they're screaming their [ __ ]
head off okay I want to say when it
comes to like serious for me I guess
it's like I don't I don't need to grieve
a relationship like if somebody passed
away yeah I'm a mess no three days only
no no no Alex three decades three
decades actually after three days that's
it and then you're pretty much [ __ ]
this is all this is all false it's gonna
be in the book
no I'm actually like the far opposite
when it comes to like any kind of like
like health or like you know a loved one
is in any kind of like problems yeah I'm
the complete opposite I can't get over
it ever like you know like I will cry
about things that happen what if he's
like listening to this podcast and he
goes three day
for 10 years
and only three days
I'd be so pissed off listen to the
podcast I was like yeah she really loved
me it was a whole year three days huh
I'll just see you next time I guess only
three days it's my whole accent so much
that's my favorite it's my dad it's so
good see just a second crying his heart
out and then you just got over it like
that you like writing music about you
and [ __ ] his next album was about you it
was almost like I was happy like not
that we were breaking it doesn't just
gets worse
it's a good thing it's not that like I
wasn't happy about breaking up but I was
like I looked on it so fondly you know
what I mean like I felt so
dramatic how everything went down
with me and Korea and K-pop and leaving
like he was also dramatic I had enough
to cry about you know and that was like
looking at that and just being like
we were we were good like we were
friends we were happy everything was
nice and it just felt like such a bright
spot that I was almost like leaving it
like with a smile like this was this was
an amazing you just dabbed them up real
quick all right bro it was great it's
been real it was good seeing you messing
you on a basketball course maybe let's
do some moves sometimes you want one
loving basketball we'll figure it out
well so what was that so why did you
leave the group
um on what happened with the whole thing
um I left the group because it was just
no longer it like it was no longer like
I only do things like that make me happy
like that's just
yeah clearly he just left this guy in a
dust
curly-haired tears
like that is definitely about her it's
like I think that's about me what makes
you think that who else had curly hair
this is my debut uh baby you this is my
debut single it's called light skin
lever
and I just want to say
she was like who the [ __ ] is this about
this
yeah I just do the reason I wanted to be
an idol is because I always wanted to be
an idol like I thought being a K-pop
Star was the ultimate it was the coolest
thing you could be and when it was it
was and when it wasn't it wasn't yeah I
didn't want to do it anymore and I just
didn't feel secure in that situation and
I just yeah I didn't want to be there
like I didn't feel felt I feel like it's
dangerous to be in situations that you
don't want to be in like if everything
is pointing to this is not serving you
at this point you just gotta go you just
gotta stop so you just didn't like the
experience anymore yeah it was horrible
like at the end it was like horrible and
I was like only staying because I felt
like had a point to prove like I felt
like
proving my supporters right is why I was
there like I felt like people who
supported me and looked at me as like
kind of like the
the
representative of like them being able
to chase their dreams like you know
black girls or you know anybody like
guys like you know I I like the fans
were everywhere I was like everyone you
know like looking at me as like the one
Speck of like diversity there and being
like Oh I can make my dreams come true
so it felt like for me to leave I felt
like I was letting so many people down
it just felt like darn it so now they're
gonna be like oh so that experiment
didn't all work and no we cannot and
aside from like the the choreographer
was there anybody else that you were
just like dude this person's a piece of
[ __ ] yeah there were I had a lot of
problems like I had I felt like
um yeah I felt like I was
not I don't know like I feel like
a lot of people didn't want to make it
work or didn't want to know me or didn't
want to like me or didn't want you know
I just felt like um I wasn't given a
shot by a lot of people do you feel that
if you had given been given the time to
learn the language that that could have
been alleviated absolutely I feel like
that's the thing like I'm not when I say
like I wasn't given a chance I don't
even like it's not like I feel like
people were being malicious
you know most people like I feel like
most people it was just a matter of like
we were so different and like I said
like for me to be Crossing all these
boundaries that I didn't know I was
crossing and then and the rest of the
group like having been together for that
long and then I come in and it's like
all this press like first you know it
was like all this attention on me and
meanwhile I'm best friends with the boss
and it didn't look good you know what I
mean like it it I can understand other
people's perspectives on it and I feel
like the same way that
I felt like judged by them they probably
felt that for me you know they probably
felt like oh she doesn't want to know us
even though I did more than anything but
it's like when you don't when you don't
speak the same language and you're under
these stressful you know scenarios all
the time you can't even defend yourself
you can't even commute that's not
clarify you can't clarify anything it's
like everything is taken at face value
everything is just taken at you know
what the best anyone can interpret it
and if like the situation is already
stressful and hard people aren't looking
to be like oh well maybe it's a
misunderstanding maybe when I think most
of our problems were misunderstandings
yeah I mean that happens a lot too
um specifically with you know a lot of
my Korean friends who've married girls
who don't speak Korean right or girls
who married guys who don't speak Korean
uh whether they're Korean or not it
doesn't matter like the the ethnicity
doesn't matter the language matters
right so one of the biggest things my
mom always asked me which is like you
don't have to marry a Korean person they
just need to know how to speak Korean so
I could talk to them that's nice you
know because for her the culture lies
within the language right and then the
culture stuff can be taught through
language and everything else so with
with her the hard part is it's like so
my brother when he had his girlfriend
was white right she couldn't speak
Korean well their relationship ends at
are you hungry are you tired how are you
yeah that's it as much as you try to
pantomime stuff or do whatever you
there's so many things you'll never ever
get to know about our family or our
culture the way I was raised who my mom
is who my dad is because the language
isn't there yes and that's the hard part
for people to understand right and I
think more or less for a lot of like uh
first gen or Generations that are like
parents who want their kids to marry
within their culture has more long lines
to do with like being able to
communicate some things that sometimes
aren't really said right you know and
the only way you can do that is having a
conversation and they can't have that
with their you know future daughter or
son-in-laws yes that's the hardest part
about it all so like even for you know
my friends too we're
I have a friend who didn't get along
with his parents I never understood why
they're like yo my dad is so [ __ ]
boring like I was like no actually he's
really really funny you just don't speak
Korean yeah you don't get the jokes you
don't get the jokes like and because he
doesn't understand the or the language
he doesn't understand the nuance and he
doesn't know when his dad's joking right
which was really hard for him and like
his dad would say something he would get
pissed because he's only interpreting it
Face Value the Nuance that's the thing
is the Nuance like for me it's like
there when your cultures are so
different and you don't speak the
language it's like you're not only just
accounting for what's said you're
accounting for what's not said you're
accounting for body language you know
what I mean it's like I didn't know
anything about any of it yeah yeah and
my experience with Korean culture having
you know Korean exchange students come
and stay with us it was like
I understood them in the context of them
trying to fit in oh in my world like I
was explaining to him because I I was
talking to his uh mom and dad and I got
to know a lot about them and they like
talking to me just because I speak
Korean so we're going back and forth
joking around whatever and I was like oh
that's cool like your dad was like a
pretty high up in like the Korean
military he goes no he wasn't I'm like
you're so dumb bro you know nothing
about your parents you're so dumb it's
like you don't know [ __ ] about your dad
man yeah he goes he never told me I was
like he can't tell you don't speak
Korean you dummy you know I was like but
how was he so tell me how was he raised
not speaking Korean in his house I mean
he could understand he can understand
but he doesn't understand like Nuance
right so it's like very somehow if both
of his parents don't really talk to the
kids like that most of the time right
except for my parents like I talk to my
mom every day that's nice but once again
I speak the language but I didn't speak
the language as well as I do now back in
the day that's why we didn't have a
relationship I took it upon myself to go
learn language more so I could speak to
her so now we get along really [ __ ]
well I was like oh my mom's actually
really funny you know she's not as much
as a [ __ ] as I thought she was she's
just [ __ ] hilarious she just doesn't
say sorry yeah no she's a [ __ ] barrier
that's why she didn't say sorry but
she's a goofy funny funny lady she has a
lot of wisdom and a lot of things that
she wants to add into a conversation but
I just didn't understand anything yeah
and so for him the sad thing is it's
like like you don't know anything about
your parents I know that's sad and you
just I have to be there not to translate
for him sometimes it's like for example
like they'll say like Korean people are
very harsh with their words like the
descriptors sometimes depending on what
area you're from you're fat I got that
one yeah oh yeah like a Korean
compliment is like
oh your face is so sweet how's that
accomplishment that's like a biggest
compliment you could I know I started to
really appreciate it over time I was
like good oh okay I get it yeah but like
they would say things like
um
well they'll just come into his room and
it's like uh like oh God your room is so
messy right and he would take it like so
seriously I was like dog it's not that
serious this is just like them just
talking like every Korean parent does
that they just make a side comment like
you're taking it too literal like you're
[ __ ] on your hygiene your mom
doesn't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] all right
she's just saying it and then because
she would always tell me why are you so
sensitive I'm like oh this is so
annoying he's an American boy yeah he's
like an American boy he doesn't
understand this type of stuff and then
you know it's also because you never try
to get to know his parents and now
they're a lot better right because after
just like me just me and a bunch of our
friends being like dude you don't you
you're misinterpreting everything yeah
you know and now their parents now they
had like their whole long talk their dad
speaks like broken English but they've
gotten a little better he's trying to
learn Korean now but now he's like not
taking everything so seriously yeah oh
this is just how they are yeah yeah so
like that language barrier is is really
hard and I mean really hard I've been
watching this uh this Korean documentary
series on YouTube where they just have
it's a bunch of foreign couples that are
together and they walk around they
document uh-huh and it's so fascinating
it's like one of my favorite things to
watch it'll be like this girl uh who met
this guy like in Chicago and they fell
in love with each other while he was
attending University as a foreign
student there and then he moved with her
to Korea and then she's like an
animation artist and then she's crying
because it's so hard for her to navigate
in curriculum speak the language she can
speak Korean decently but she doesn't
have the confidence and so in a job like
I could speak casually to somebody in
Korean right but in terms of a formal
sense because I never spoke formal
Korean I don't know how to do it yes
I'll just come off as a disrespectful
[ __ ] right you know and that's a big
deal I don't want to be that exactly so
like I'm talking there's like your
regular conversations like and I don't
know how to speak to my very well right
so I remember when I was with my lady
and I was talking to um like some of her
relatives just cracking up she goes why
it's like you talk to people like you're
a [ __ ] Thug and I'm like oh I don't
know how else to speak that's how my mom
talks yeah she goes like you you you
don't understand like the hierarchy in
the language I was like no you're 100
right I don't I only know how to speak
the Korean that I was taught with my mom
and my mom's a piece of [ __ ] so I speak
like a piece of [ __ ] so she was like no
your Korean is great it's just like very
inappropriate that's so funny yeah and I
had no idea but that language part is so
important like just having that part of
your culture is like I I'm always going
to go for it right yeah I love diversity
but I also like the reason why things
like diversity is celebrated is because
you know your culture yeah so when
people always say this thing like oh I
don't really see colors like I I think
everybody should be mixed 100 I believe
in like diversity in that type of sense
but I don't think you have to throw away
where you're from just to be a part of a
group right and you can see color yeah
not in a negative light right yeah you
could see it and then appreciate it yes
exactly that's the thing that people
don't understand and they go I don't see
colors like yes you [ __ ] do because
you're a hundred percent I see color all
the time but the difference between me
and you is like I celebrate it yeah you
know I celebrate that language I
celebrate what they do and how they are
yeah and that's the fun part of things
right that's why we like traveling and
[ __ ] yeah I still can't believe you
lived in Korea that's nice to me yeah
and I would do it again have you have
you ever had like any bad dating
situations like in Korea because I know
like culturally it's just so different
no I didn't have any bad dating
situations
um everyone was so nice yeah like
everyone was so nice they're so polite
that's like one of the things I
appreciate most about Korea is that like
what at first I really perceived as like
coldness that I really didn't like I
realized it was not coldness at all it
was like respect it was like the
opposite it was like respect and it was
like a formality to it but everybody is
polite like and it like you said like
they're considerate of what other people
are perceiving and at first I was like
everyone is cold yeah oh no everyone is
just being respectful of each other and
then I really love that then I came back
here and I was like Ugh people are so
rude
it's like personal space is a big thing
dude I told this funny story on this
podcast a while back but there was a
friend of mine who started doing online
dating and it was this Korean guy she's
Taiwanese cute little girl
she meets up this dude and she's I've
been going through her dating profiles
stuff right and some of these guys are
[ __ ] losers like I could not believe
like the [ __ ] that they would say like
on like these Tinder dating apps what's
on their profile like their bio things
yeah it's like I understand why you're
single like you are so bad at this
you're so bad at selling yourself yeah
and so she meets this dude and you know
she's like okay where do you want to
meet she goes well he goes I want to
meet at Porto's I haven't had Porto's in
a while I'm like well that's the first
terrible first date first it's like the
most busiest [ __ ] place ever there's
nowhere to sit already and she she
already she goes do you see what I'm
saying and I'm like convincing you're
like give him a chance whatever just try
it out she goes there she goes is that
portals right he she messages like hey
I'm here where are you he goes I'm
somewhere inside come find me them
strike two for sure like
what the [ __ ] I'm leaving yeah I'll have
time so she's like okay whatever they
get coffee together they sit down right
and I [ __ ] you [ __ ] not this is like
during Corona uh two cups of coffee he
goes oh what are you drinking she goes
oh I got this drink
it goes up grabs her drink puts his
[ __ ] mouth on I died I'm done he puts
his [ __ ] mouth on it drinks it and
puts it and she looks at him and she
goes
did you just drink out of my drink he
goes oh did she say it with that face or
did she like play it off was she like
did you just drink out of my dream I
don't know how she said it but she was
like did you drink out of my drink and
then she said that oh he goes oh he goes
oh like you know I'm Korean I was like
hold on second stop stop that is not a
Korean thing don't you [ __ ] dare that
is not a Korean thing that's not a
Korean thing you come up and grab
somebody a drink and drink out of it you
[ __ ] idiot like the audacity and he
was like he put it on the culture I was
like no no no no no I was like that's
not a crate that's what he said I don't
give a [ __ ] what he says that's not a
Korean thing Korean people respect each
other's personal space a lot yes like
it's a very important part of us you
don't just come up to a stranger and go
like hey what's in there wow you know
and then no you do not he puts it back
and she goes
yeah like you just drank out of magic he
goes oh I'm sorry he goes up and she
goes oh he's going to get me a drink
yeah he comes back with the new straw it
just gives her no seriously that's so
funny no I thought for sure he would go
and get I'm sorry get a new drinks
she kind of cuts the date super early
and he goes hey I had a good time like
do you want to see each other again she
goes no no
she's no thank you thank you it was
great meeting you when she leaves in a
couple days
and then she leaves it's a message and
he goes hey I talked to a couple friends
of mine and uh I think what I did was
really inappropriate
I was like hold on you needed to talk to
a couple of people you needed to consult
because I guess in his mind he thought
the date went great yeah he's like why
doesn't she want to and I'm pretty sure
he told the same story but they were
like you did what
you [ __ ] put your filthy [ __ ]
Corona mouth on her drink and then just
got her Australian he's like I'm Korean
they're like no no we're Korean too you
don't [ __ ] do that
the most craziest thing ever dude it's
wild I like I don't I've never got to do
online dating so I never neither oh
you've never done it you say get to
I never got to do that like I kind of
wanted to know what it's like I don't
you know okay I don't know maybe it's
because I'm a girl I'm scared I'm scared
of everybody like I I assume all
strangers are gonna what was your last
try to kidnap and kill me
I love dates okay last date probably
recently
maybe weeks maybe three weeks ago maybe
so is are you just dating for fun right
now and this thing what's up or
yeah I'm always dating for fun
like here's the thing too like I love
flirting like flirting and stuff is all
great right but then like the whole
dating aspect sometimes gets really
tired for me because it's like I get it
because you're a guy well yeah I think
it's probably harder of course
I love that I love it
because you're a pretty little K-pop
girl all right put on a dress yeah
but like go have some fun so okay love
it what's what's one of the worst dating
stories that you've ever had well there
was one you know honestly I I've been
pretty lucky in love I will say
or dating maybe not love but I'm lucky
and dating
um but there was one guy in New York who
um wanted to play guess my weight
like I didn't ask for that game to be
played what the [ __ ] are you doing he
was like how much do you think I weigh I
was like I don't know he's like how tall
you think I am I'm like I don't know and
I'm really bad at that I'm like
notoriously like I don't know like if
you I don't know I don't know I don't
know how old somebody is I don't know
how much I weigh I don't know how tall I
don't know yeah I don't know yeah I
don't know
so wait why would he ask that I don't
know what was the point what was his
conversation supposed to go I don't know
I didn't know where it was going but I
said I don't know and then he goes okay
let me guess yours I was like oh did you
just say that so you could guess mine
because he wants to know how much you
weigh yeah and then he goes five two uh
170.
I was like no
are you a power lifter
do you lift tractors for a living are
you talking about five to 170 pounds
five two my buddy
yeah this guy's terrible he was terrible
I don't remember I don't I don't even
know what back then I think I was less
scared of strangers than I am now like
now in order to date you have to be
accounted for like you know what I mean
like I have to know you through somebody
has there has to we ever have a
connection yes I'm not
we're not doing just the random no you
might who knows you could kill me okay
so you're super scared of that [ __ ] yeah
I'm gonna die what about if you just
meet up in a public space I don't trust
it
I don't trust it people do stuff you
don't even think of like me like like
say it's the uh [ __ ] uh the Americana
like in broad daylight at a cafe outside
they put something in your drink put
their arm around you slide you out of
there how about you just hold your drink
close to you
listen I'm not going to have to you know
I'm not gonna have to hold my drink
close to me I'm gonna go on a date and
it's gonna be fine you think they're not
gonna be worrying about my drink that is
CR but you know what happens right you
know like stuff like this happens more
to people that you know than people you
don't know like statistically like women
who get sexually assaulted and attacked
are from all people that they know yes
you are right about that yeah last night
that's very funny because I was reading
that thinking huh
I'm in danger every time I've been like
so careful and I'm actually putting
myself in more danger but you know what
I'm also a really good judge
real good
real good then you should be fine going
out on these days but I don't want to
I don't want to
I want to go I want to go out with
someone who's accounted for
but those are the worst ones they're the
[ __ ] worst ones listen
not they don't have to just be accounted
for they have to pass my eye test okay
and that
that's a strict test yeah
in a public space and look at their face
sit down and be like you're scared and
then walk away yeah I could but you know
what I'm also too nice for that so
that's the problem
your drink and they'll be like no that's
Alka cell so I swear to God it is and
I'm like oh my God take a sip no yeah I
don't need to be in that position
because like I do get to a point where
it's like I don't want to be mean so
it's like I try to I try to
I try to I limit my I limit my contact
with the outside world
highly like I'm really limited I'm
really like like it's I'm here
we're here are you an introvert then
because you seem more extroverted yeah I
don't even know I feel like I don't know
it's like on Tick Tock where they're
like as an empath yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't freaking
know I um I like to stay I like to stay
home most of the time but I also like a
really fun date
um
I like to write all day by myself I like
to dance all night and then I like to go
on a date for my dinner are you are you
that sounded wrong it sounds like I have
a date every single month in order to
eat dinner that's what I mean I mean I
have I haven't paid for a meal in
[ __ ] 10 years I mean that's my window
of dating it's like I I don't it can't
interfere with my schedule already but
like there's the window of like okay I
need to eat so we can do that I'm
curious like what what is it what is it
that you look for in a partner
um
Democrat okay there's one for sure
um
vegetarian vegetarian or vegan or vegan
either one will do
um it has to be vegetarian vegan I'm
just not yeah I'm just not into watching
me going into somebody's mouth and then
them trying to kiss me with their me
mouth that is the most pornographic
thing I've ever heard in my life
slightly turned on let's keep it going
all right here we go
um I mean I've dated people who eat meat
obviously the guy can create meat of
course this is a more recent development
where it's like you know just the the
more I lean into you know my dietary
thing it's just like you said it makes
more sense like I want to go to a vegan
restaurant so it works when a guy wants
to also go to a vegan restaurant so when
you see somebody cut into a steak that
just makes you sick yeah I don't like it
holy [ __ ] it's not for me did you do
[ __ ] like Ayahuasca or some [ __ ] to
make you feel this way because I only
say this because I know two people who
did like shrooms and they became [ __ ]
Vision I'm sorry I don't even know what
we're talking about what's it like it's
uh psychedelics
I've never touched a drug I've never
drank I've never done anything you never
[ __ ] dried
there's no [ __ ] way you can do
business without drinking in Korea yeah
I know that's what they said repeatedly
oh my God I guess that's why I'm back
that's crazy so you've never drank
alcohol ever wow I almost feel like I
had to so I I drink when I started my
first drink was like 14 or 13. 13 or 14
some [ __ ] like that with your parents no
hell no that was with my cousin yeah we
had a we had a heavy on bottle and we
filled it up with Remy Martin and then
we just drank that whole bottle and I
woke up in a stupor the next day I
didn't know what the [ __ ] was I just it
never sounded good to me like right now
that didn't sound good terrible so I
don't know why what's a why well I don't
want to I mean it's different for people
right so I like the taste of beer like
but I don't like the taste of excessive
beer so like beer like if I have a beer
it's great once it goes to the second
one it tastes weird to me I don't know
why but that first beer always tastes
good so
um and people like being drunk because
it makes them feel loose that's the
biggest so that's the thing they're like
oh how come you don't like smoking if
you don't if you like drinking
difference when I smoke I don't feel
like myself I feel like I can't control
the things that I'm saying I can't like
everything
I hate it I hate it so much but if I'm
drinking I may be like compromise but I
don't know it so I I'm confident as [ __ ]
yeah so it's such a different [ __ ]
feel I'm not saying if you don't like
you should should drink I think you
should like if there's no point I don't
drink that much I'm a social drinker so
like if you go to my house the only time
that there's alcohol is next to the
podcast station because that's the only
time I drink but in my fridge itself
there's no beers there's no nothing like
I think I don't like if I'm at home I
don't crack open a beer yeah I do it if
they're with somebody right it's like
it's you know it's based off a communion
type of thing yeah but damn you never
drink or anything so so wait vegetarian
vegan is a bonus Democrat is a must what
else yeah I like how you said that bonus
must for sure
um really I just like you have to be
nice like that's really all I care about
I like someone who's like really nice
like I I don't like someone who's mean
at all I don't like someone who I don't
need to change anybody I don't need to
be your mom I have none of that I don't
want to do any of it please I do not
what do you want to tell you what to do
nice just someone who is so kind who
just does for others you know and cares
for other I just oh I love that you just
got to be caring and kind and like such
a good person I just like to know that
you're a good person like I watch how
you treat people and
if you're rude and you're not you know I
don't like it so you're like walking
down the street this guy like walks his
grandma across the streets and you're
like I'm [ __ ] horny right now dude
and the guy's like what what's wrong
with you
what are you doing why are you staring
at me he's like dude keep walking that
old ass lady across the street and see
what happens dude that's [ __ ] funny
so you like people who are really kind
um Democrat and white Democrat why is
that so important to you I don't want
anyone who doesn't hold my genuine
genuine that was great I want to say
General yeah and genuine
genuine my general like what sense of
right and wrong
I can't be with someone who doesn't
share that sense of right and wrong yeah
I could see that I [ __ ] with gay people
but I'll still [ __ ] with somebody who
eats Chick-fil-A
because I'm one of the Chick-fil-A thing
happened and I was eating a Chick-fil-A
they're like did you hear what they said
I was like I know this sandwich is
delicious and I love gay people and also
that person next to me also gay even a
Chick-fil-A Sandwich so it's pretty cool
so I'm okay yeah so you're fine yeah I
understand what you mean I I just like
maybe it's just because I'm I'm okay
with like differing opinions a lot with
even the people that I'm with because it
creates like good conversation and you
kind of like learn a little bit more
about yourself when you do disagree if I
have an echo chamber I'm not learning
anything so like for example I used to
date this girl who she was so scared of
losing me
um so she wanted to be this perfect girl
like this perfect girlfriend even though
I'm in shambles so if I said something
she I agree with you if I said something
I'm like hold on a second and I remember
I had this conversation with her and
this was one of the biggest reasons why
I dumped her was because like I was like
you know we've been together for 10
months now and I don't know you and
she's like why I was like because
everything you say you agree with she
goes I was like and I genuinely don't
think you agree with this stuff I was
like you are so scared to be yourself
because you're afraid that I'm going to
leave you if you and AI butt heads and
she goes I just want to be a good
girlfriend I'm like that's not being a
good girlfriend like you are not I don't
own you you are your individual self you
and I might Clash we might argue and we
might fight or bicker or whatever
whatnot but we're supposed to get over
that and then learn how to communicate
with each other effectively but as of
right now even sometimes when I say
things out of emotions I know that I'm
wrong but then you agree with me and I
hate that you agree with me right you
know what I mean because I have to step
back and when I realized like oh [ __ ]
that was kind of disrespectful why did I
say that yeah and I apologize to you and
then you go no I was wrong it makes me
feel like I'm like snuffing out your
light like I hate that [ __ ] yeah yeah so
I was like so we broke up and I was like
listen you need to go find yourself like
because you clearly are you identify
yourself with how happy I am when your
happiness should be based on what you
think and what you believe yeah so like
for me to have people who are hyper
agreeable around me it's not something
that I really enjoy I like people who
are civil and can have conversations
yeah um because most of my friends we
disagree on a lot of [ __ ] yeah you know
I don't mind disagreeing on things like
you know over easy or scrambled yeah
right
right yeah
just for me it's just it's core values
it's like core values have to line up if
they don't it's just 100 for me and I
can't but yeah I I like to debate too so
I'm always down for like a good
all right would you like scrambled or
[ __ ] I'm a vegan yeah oh that's like
just egg oh are you do you are you no
eggs or anything yeah I'm not right yeah
like I um well you switch to every now
I'm vegetarian for like a long time and
then I go through like I've been like
vegan on and off like in Korea I was
vegan for a minute and it was like
impossible like yeah it's hard
especially with an Adventures [ __ ]
fish sauce yeah I was like okay like
they would and also they didn't even
understand vegan so they would just
bring me those hard-boiled eggs oh Jesus
Christ you know and they're like
you know like oh and then I didn't even
want to tell them like oh it's you know
they thought they were talking good like
they got for everybody else like food
and then for me they would bring me
these eggs and I'm like oh they think
they did a good job yeah yeah you don't
want to like you know you're just being
polite yeah so then like I would try to
like tell them like oh yeah like in the
future you know but anyway so it ended
up that like you know I was eating a lot
of those eggs so you know I wasn't vegan
anymore but yeah right now so I went
yeah okay and then you did um so but
you'll well you eat eggs every now and
then if you have to um I mean when I was
veggie like when I was vegetarian and
not vegan like yeah eggs were fine I
don't like eggs to be honest with you oh
that's my favorite thing about that I
like that let me tell you what though I
like the steamed eggs in Korea oh the
current team yeah around oh my gosh like
those were great for me it's just like
sometimes eggs always just tasted too
eggy like I sometimes I should call it
like a little weird taste where it's
like see that makes sense when I talk to
somebody like you it makes more sense
for me like some of my friends who are
who I'm vegan vegetarian these [ __ ]
lasted two months a month and I was like
they're like I couldn't do it I was like
I know you couldn't do it because you're
doing this on some weird moral High
Ground like my vegetarian friends who
stay vegetarian because they just didn't
they didn't like the taste they didn't I
like the taste of meat oh do you yes
damn so it's like a moral thing for you
for sure damn all my friends who did the
moral [ __ ] they [ __ ] failed after two
months yeah no now they just now they're
just more conscious about where they get
their with their uh protein and stuff
which I was like this is probably the
easier route for you right and also too
like in Korean food aside from like
before like American influence and like
we are our affluents majority of our
stuff didn't have that much meat it was
like a lot of it was in a stew or so
like Korean barbecue that was like a
luxury like you don't just go out and
eat a [ __ ] ton of meats it's very
expensive but now that we're like in
this affluent stage now there's a lot
more meat that's why also Korean people
are getting a lot more like they're
having a lot more health issues like
they're a lot more overweight and stuff
so I did appreciate though in Korea how
like when we would go somewhere to eat I
never had a problem because with you
know just the panchan on the side yeah
being a vegetarian is a lot easier but
being vegan is damn near impossible yeah
vegan was tough but it was more so just
because of my circumstance in the
schedule it was like there wasn't a way
for me to arrange my own meals all the
time you know it's like we're here we're
there we're you know we're running on
and off stage and we like have one
second to eat and which is whatever
they're handing you and
um so it just you kind of have to plan
in order to really be vegan you have to
be able to like plan like okay am I
gonna have food at this time am I gonna
have food here is there something I can
eat but um when I was vegetarian when we
would go to restaurants it was great
people are like can you you know are you
okay yeah I would like have the guinea
you know the yeah yeah and I put just
like I would put the kimchi thing and
heat it put it in there you know what
the [ __ ] is going on yeah and they're
like you're not putting the samkips out
yeah like they're like what are you
doing but it was so good it was like my
favorite meal I'm like no I love this
like warmed up kimchi with the leaves
yeah it was so good and then I have you
know this the sweet potato salad on the
side it's like there's so many things I
could eat
just on side and I love that about
Korean food yeah like you're veganism
hard man like maybe not so much in
California it's not as hard yeah it's
actually like my favorite restaurant
here is vegan just it is like NYX on
Beverly it's like my favorite it's so
good and it's not loves that place too
not yeah yeah not because it's vegan
because I love it I can't do it just
based on the fact that it just limits my
variety of food because you don't like
Nick's on Beverly no I I like Nixon
Beverly's good Oh I thought when you
said you could do it Oh I thought you
couldn't do it it limits like the amount
of food that you could have in the world
you know what I mean no I like somebody
that's probably one of the better vegan
spots you can go to yeah like the amount
of food that you could eat in this world
is limited like to if you're just vegan
or vegetarian yeah that's like the the
hard part for me because I love food
like even [ __ ] that I don't like I try
three or four times just to make sure I
don't like it yeah yeah so like that's
like the the hard part because for me
I'm not a big protein guy the only
reason I started eating more protein now
is because I lost a lot of weight
because I just I like some rice in my
noodles yeah I do [ __ ] me too I was
in Hawaii and I ate rice every [ __ ]
day I gained eight pounds or six days
amazing happy is eight pounds of my life
and then I come back I just don't eat
rice and I've dropped six pounds Rice
and Noodles are so good yeah it's a
[ __ ] drink let's do this if you could
only have I always ask everyone this
rice or noodles
forever like you can never have one of
them again I don't know if I phrase that
right you know what I'm saying yeah it's
rice or it's noodles rice
I [ __ ] love pasta like if I can't
have pasta sometimes macaroni that's
good yeah that's gonna kill me too like
but I love like Don booties I love
pibimbap kimbap a lot of my stuff is
related emotions and kimbap
are good they're not better than nanyan
to me or japchae I take Japanese over
bibimbap gimbap see I can't do that
definitely because top two is a side
dish I can't just eat a side I can give
it all to me that's just not as salty as
[ __ ] it's so delicious I I literally I
eat it all the time I mean you could
definitely make veg a vegan
delicious just have to get vegan soy
sauce and you're pretty good it's good
to go yeah oh interesting
oh touches the most you know touch is
the most [ __ ] annoying thing to make
on Earth I can see that just because
like I've had them where like the
noodles have soaked up the sauce for too
long it's annoying because there's too
many [ __ ] ingredients that's why I
hate making it will you make it though I
can if you want vegan one I would I
could probably yeah does your lady like
japchae uh she likes everything she
doesn't dislike anything but even for
her she's not vegetarian vegan but she
might as well be for the way she eats
she doesn't eat a lot of meat so she
kind of eats like Greenery and stuff
like that Greenery Greenery eats that
Greenery well guys that wraps up this
episode of The Genius brain podcast got
to know a little bit more about Alex she
likes to date people so guess what get
in them [ __ ] pants right now all
right get in there get in there [ __ ]
curly head Beauty Wonder here where can
they find you and when are you gonna
drop that book
um I I'm planning on the novel being
released in August 2023. I want the
Memoir to come out after because I
wanted to kind of be like this is the
story and then I want people to be like
wait wait like what's facts yeah what's
not so I just that's kind of the setup I
would like so novel first and then
Memoir following whatever the demand
looks like you know hopefully soon after
awesome where can they find you on
Instagram and everything else um the
Alex read on Instagram Alex Reid and
um tick tock tick tock baby that's my
favorite I don't like social media and I
love Tick Tock okay
um Fairy Godmother read Fairy Godmother
read Fairy Godmother mother mother it's
gonna be in the description box Fairy
Godmother read go well do you sprint
every Sundays at 12pm we'll see y'all
next time peace
I know
[Music]